this is one of the most isolated
supermarkets on Earth but it sure
doesn't look like it after all it's in
Hawaii which despite its name
recognition and visitor count is by most
definitions the most remote major
population Center on Earth there are
more isolated islands and archipelagos
and atol but nowhere on Earth is there a
concentration of a million or more
people farther from the next nearest
concentration of a million it's as far
from Los Angeles as New York as far from
Anchorage as Norway as far from Japan as
Afghanistan between Hawaii and the
California coast there's truly nothing
no towns no people not even a single
island of any size save for the few just
off the coast of Los Angeles the
shortest commercial international flight
from Hawaii is to a tiny ATL known as
Christmas Island populated by just 7,000
people and that's an anomaly the next
nearest is to maero in the Marshall
Islands 4 and 1 half hours away but it's
not Fiji a 6-hour flight from Honolulu
that the population comes even close to
that of Hawaii that's all to say it's
weird how normal this grocery store
looks considering where it is isolation
typically restricts convenience yet look
inside and the shelves are stocked
essentially exactly the same as they'd
be if this was say a Safeway in Seattle
and not just with the Shelf stable
products even these bananas originate
from exactly where they would for most
of the Continental us they've traveled
from Ecuador so quickly in fact that
they're not even right it's not until
one looks at the prices of perishables
$10 for a gallon of whole milk that
anything deviates from what would be the
expectation on the mainland Hawaii is
firmly integrated in the American supply
chain to the extent that differences in
its Retail Landscape are surprisingly
tough to come by dueling chicken
retailers Chick-fil-A and raising canes
for example recently expanded to the
state both of which have next to no
International presence and therefore for
no builtup International Supply chains
neither has an overwhelming incentive to
expand to Hawaii it is an untapped
Market sure but there's nothing about
the state that would make it worth it
for either to develop a brand new system
of sourcing and shipping product just to
open a couple dozen additional locations
so this is as good a sign as any that
somehow these isolated islands are so
logistically linked to the US that it's
just about as easy for a brand to expand
there as anywhere in the US and it's
true Hawaii supply chain offers a near
seamless experience for its users the
shops restaurants and other businesses
operating in the state but the supply
chain itself is anything but normal much
of its uniqueness stems from one
American law known as the Jones act its
rules are simple with a little exception
only ships registered in the US built in
the US and staffed by Americans can
transport goods between us ports the
original idea was to protect the US
Merchant Marine and ship building
Industries partially to keep competency
in case major seal of capacity is needed
for a large scale War abroad but these
days this ends up being rather
restrictive as the vast majority of
oceangoing container ships are
registered in countries with favorable
tax and labor policies like Panama or
Liberia and primarily staffed by
Mariners from low wage countries like
the Philippines or India what this means
in practice is that the industry often
ends up with exploitative labor
practices environmentally damaging
construction processes and other
undesired externalities but the end
result is a rock bottom operating prices
a fraction of those of us ships in fact
the cost of operating a Jones act
compliant cargo ship is estimated
between 3 to six times the norm so in a
free market these ships simply wouldn't
exist they could never be competitive if
not for this law the total number of
Jones act compliant containers ships in
the entire world is just 23 and all but
five of those are operated by one of two
companies matsim and Pasha Hawaii this
pair of companies represent the vast
majority of inbound shipping capacity to
Hawaii and yet they likely would not
exist if not for the Jones act that's
because even beyond the normally lower
operating cost of international shipping
companies there's great asymmetry of
demand across the Pacific in September
2024 the average cost to ship a 40-foot
container from Shanghai to Los Angeles
was about $6,000 where shipping the same
container on the same route in Reverse
Los Angeles to Shanghai cost just $700
that's all down to supply and demand
North America Imports far more from Asia
than Asia does from North America so
ships typically return West with far
less Hawaii is a rare instance of
westbound demand across the Pacific so
if not for the Jones act some
international shipping companies would
likely add it as a stop on the return
trip to Asia to drop off cargo on the
typically unprofitable leg but instead
Matson and Pasha Hawaii operate the
services charging far far more to move
the same 40ft container now now their
services do differ slightly from the
global Norm for container shipping
largely sense normally container
shipping is just not a very
time-sensitive Endeavor globally cargo
ships operate at an average speed of
just 15 knots despite a typical vessel
top speed of over 20 this is since ocean
shipping companies compete primarily on
cost not speed and operating slower is
more fuel efficient Hawaii ships
meanwhile typically operate at over 20
knots in order to transport Goods to the
state in just 3 or 4 days uniquely these
ship do compete on speed since they need
to fit into the typical window of time
it takes to get perishable products from
distribution centers to stores these
bananas from Ecuador for example likely
left the country on Dole's dedicated
container ship the Dole Pacific up to
their facility in San Diego from there
they might otherwise spend a few days
getting trucked to a grocery
Distribution Center in say Salt Lake
City wait around for a day then get
trucked up to a grocery store in
Missoula so the route to Hawaii is not
necessarily that much longer than that
to an inland State a day or two to get
up to matson's terminal in Long Beach 4
days to get to Honolulu West Coast ports
like Long Beach and Oakland are major
Logistics hubs and 3 to 4 day proximity
to them is well within normal time
frames for distribution what's less
normal is the cost Jones act's compliant
operators have to pay high ship building
costs they have to pay high labor costs
so they do what they can to reduce cost
where possible for example on some
sailings they'll return to the West
Coast at that slower more efficient
speed on a recent trip the Pasha George
2 left Long Beach on Wednesday September
4th sailed at 20 knots then arrived in
Honolulu 4 days later on Sunday
following unloading and loading it left
Honolulu on Monday but only sailed at
about 15 knots and didn't get back to
Long Beach until the following Monday a
week later Hawaii doesn't export much
these days especially in terms of
perishable Goods so this slower speed is
fine as another technique Matson also
Services a unique route that helps
capture eastbound demand and therefore
maximize utilization as certain continue
on to Guam Guam is an American territory
and although it has far lower demand
than Hawaii both due to lower population
and more International imports from
nearby Nations like Japan it does still
import plenty from the mainland but
after calling it Guam Ms and ships don't
continue back to the US they go on to
the Japanese island of okanawa which
also Imports plenty from the US due to
the massive US military presence there
before continuing on to Shanghai there
the world's busiest container Port
they've built a small niche as the
provider of the f fastest us-bound
Services While most container traffic is
not very time dependent on such a
massive route there's clearly some for
much of recent history maton was able to
provide this speed because their ships
are comparatively small Shanghai
naturally is a fairly shallow water Port
so the larger ships used by competitors
couldn't load to full capacity there and
therefore they typically make another
stop to load fully before continuing on
to North America Shanghai has since
artificially deepened its Port making
this less of the case but Matson still
tout speed due to faster loading times
from their smaller vessel size full 20
knot operating speeds and then on the US
side they operate their own dedicated
terminals at ports like Oakland and Long
Beach allowing them to avoid the kind of
pork congestion that reached headlines
during Co in fact Freight rates reached
such astronomical Heights during Co that
despite their High operating costs
Matson could briefly meaningfully
compete especially given their speed and
they took some capacity away from Hawaii
to expand service from Asia but now back
in normal times strategies such as their
Asia service are increasingly for Matson
as they get used to competition after
all for much of its history Matson
enjoyed a near complete Monopoly on
Hawaii shipping services and Pasha
Hawaii's challenge since it first
started service in 2005 has pushed
prices down and introduced genuine
competition for the first time in a
while but monopolies still exist in
Hawaiian Logistics you see every single
container from the continental US first
arrives here at the Port of Honolulu on
aahu but Hawaii also encompasses Kawai
Maui and the big Islands plus a few
other more minor Islands so to get
containers Beyond Honolulu one must hire
a barge and there's one and only one
company that offers barge service
between the islands young Brothers now
Matson does operate its own barges that
connect some of its containers that
originated in the mainland to certain
other Hawaiian ports but the only
carrier that is currently Allowed by the
state to sell container transport
between the islands exclusively is Young
Brothers the logic behind the state
sanctioned Monopoly is that Hawaii can
therefore require young Brothers to
service unprofitable ports in sparsely
populated lenai and Malachai and the
state also regulates the rates young
Brothers charges but there's still an
eye popping sum transporting a loaded
container from Honolulu to any of the
other ports which typically takes about
a day costs
$1,412
189 as in twice what shippers are
currently charging to transport the same
container from Los Angeles to
shangai and it's not like there are
other Jones act compliant barge
operators that could replace Young
brothers' service at moment's notice and
the state knows this when in 2020 the
company came to the state and said the
rates they were allowed to charge would
lead to a financial loss of $30 million
the state had essentially no option but
to agree to a 46% hike in rates less
risk losing their only way of getting
goods between the islands the state
itself has admitted in an audit of the
company that young Brothers has gotten
used to being able to pass on any
increase in cost to the consumers and
therefore has little incentive to be
diligent in reducing them so when you
combine the geography of isolation with
federal and state legislation that
restricts competition when ends up with
dramatically higher costs than those of
the Mainland compare the prices of the
Whole Food supermarket in Long Beach
California closest to the port where
much of Hawaii's Goods originate and
that of the island of Maui now one can
find similar prices for certain shelf
stable Goods a bottle of olive oil is
just a dollar more in Hawaii for example
but consistently the fresher something
is the more expensive it is versus the
mainland round beef goes from $6.99 to
$8.99 cabbage from $149 a pound to
$2.79 lemons from $ 89 to $49 a pack of
eggs from $369 to
$599 as a state Hawaii Imports around
95% of its food there is next to zero in
state production and almost all of that
food rides on one of two shipping
carriers from the mainland then one
shipping carrier between the island
there certainly are edge cases a small
portion of food gets flown in by plane
there are some imports from abroad but
in some there's incredible Reliance on
one single Logistics system with
uniquely artificially high costs but
over recent years stale leaders have
started to recognize that the downsides
go beyond just costs it's also just
risky you see all Mainland container
cargo gets unloaded here at the Port of
Honolulu with no exception this is the
only commercial port in the state that
has the cranes necessary to unload the
kind of large oceangoing cargo ships
used by Matson and Pasha Hawaii those on
the other islands are only capable of
accepting and unloading smaller barges
so there is a single facility capable of
bringing large quantities of goods into
the islands and it's on the coast that
means the fear is twofold tsunamis and
hurricanes either of these disasters
could render the cranes used to unload
ships inoperable and even if they did
the ports are well within the possible
inundation zones for either meaning the
surrounding infrastructure like the
roads used to bring containers out and
staff in could be flooded and damaged
for an extended period having recognized
this the state did invest in a large
portable crane capable of unloading
containers and that's stored at Pearl
Harbor the military base which is
earmarked to operate as an alternate
port in the event of Honolulu becoming
inoperable but estimates suggest this
plan could only accommodate between 15
and 20% of normal cargo inflows and as
the recent incident at the port
Baltimore demonstrated disruption to
Port operations can last months of
course airports and roll on rolloff
ships could provide a back stop for
Necessities in the event of major
natural disaster but the concentration
of infrastructure in the port of
Honolulu means that if it gets damaged
or disrupted it could take quite a while
for life in Hawaii to get back to normal
but it doesn't have to be this way in
fact it wasn't some 100 m or 160 km in
three islands over from Pearl Harbor a
long Maui's dry West Coast just north of
the sunny kiaka Beach and bumping up
against the manicured landscape
surrounding the undeniably Aging Maui
Paradise oceanfront condo is what
visitors describe as a pleasant waiting
pool or a shallow Lagoon within which
one can see small fish and turtles up
close but what these reviewers missed
was the fact that this is not just a
convenience for tourists but a
historical artifact a physical
explanation for how ancient Hawaii fed
itself for centuries before European
contact and centuries upon centuries
before the Advent of modern container
ships this is a coastal fish pond one of
about 360 that dotted the Hawaiian
Islands at the time of James Cook's
arrival in 1778 and one of the last
vestages of an intricate aquaculture
structure that stretched from sea to
Mountaintop now there's two major
natural particularities that broadly
Define the Hawaiian Islands first as a
rugged volcanic outcropping the islands
are generally mountainous with high
points on the larger islands ranging
from a few thousand ft above sea level
to well over 10,000 ft above sea level
second they don't receive precipitation
evenly the High Country and the north
and east sides receive feet upon feet of
rain annually while the dry Southwestern
sides measure their precipitation in
inches faced with rugged Uplands and
flatter but drier lowlands Hawaiian
agriculture took shape around holistic
watersheds letting gravity do most of
the work following streams gushing out
from the higher elevation forests
Hawaiian would Strate rically Dam or
divert sections to flood fields for
non-native terot a carbohydrate dietary
staple the growing Taro in turn would
provide food and shelter for fish such
as mullet and silver perch providing yet
more food and nutrients water released
from these catchments would then flow
into lower freshwater ponds where
freshwater prawn and sea migrating fish
would spawn in turn these nutrient-rich
Waters would then fill brackish ponds
then seawater ponds connected by canals
and separated by gates from the larger
that would let smaller fish in without
letting bigger fish escape with
comparatively minimal alteration of the
landscape and with only the strength of
a human Workforce Hawaiians through
aquaculture supplemented with animal
husbandry and traditional agriculture
achieved sustainable food sovereignty of
course it goes without saying that such
a system was in part made possible by a
marketly different property ownership
structure a subsistence lifestyle rather
than an extractive one and a feudal
organization of Labor that's long been
left behind but it also that without
much in the way of technology and with
the Strategic use of non-native crops
Hawaii could sustainably produce food
for a population that's been estimated
to have touched 700 to 900,000
inhabitants at the time of Western
contact there are only remnants of this
aquaculture system left today the
arrival of Europeans in Western disease
decimated native populations while
Western interpretations of land use and
property rights culminated in the 1848
great Mahal a legal transition of land
ownership from a fuel regime into
private property not far from Ki in the
city of l once a residence of King
kamehame II now a city rebuilding after
unprecedented but entirely explainable
wildfires and one of these historically
Central ponds sat under an unspectacular
Park and some tennis courts and not so
far down the road standing 225 ft in the
air is another artifact that largely
informed the Pond's destruction while
the Jones act may explain why food is so
expensive to import it sugarcane and
pineapples that begin to explain why
Hawaii has to import food in the first
place for a concentrated few the
proliferation of steam powered ships the
Advent of the California Gold Rush then
the American Civil War and the newly
established ability to purchase Hawaiian
land in the mid 1880s proved a Bonafide
bonanza with cheap land cheap labor
minimal oversight and maximum
exploitation the rich arable Hawaiian
lowlands turned from food producers to
cash crop producers as the only
agriculture diversity stemmed from what
was being monocropped sugar cane or
pineapples peaking in the 1950s the
plantation era dominated Hawaiian
agriculture for more than a century
effectively turning a self-sustaining
Sovereign food system into a cash crop
exporter but with statehood came
increased regulation and labor rights
and with the jet age came increased
accessibility suddenly Hawaii wasn't
some vague American holding impossibly
far away but now a tropical destined
nation that didn't require a passport
port with stricter labor laws and higher
wages increased competition for real
estate and increasing competition abroad
monocropping slowly seated economic
centrality to tourism with a growing
population and an increasing visitor
count Hawaii now needed more food than
ever and yet after a century of
Relentless exporting could produce less
than ever while some small Hawaiian
Farms began to infill shuttering
Plantation lands the cheapest fastest
way to keep the islands Fed was
importing with beef Imports fruit
Imports and vegetable Imports all
doubling from 1960 to 2000 the islands
went from producing somewhere around
half their own food to less than a tenth
this rather new system has started to
have some real consequences the Hawaiian
cost of living crisis is severe it is
the most expensive state to live in by a
wide margin and food prices are far from
all of it the housing market is perhaps
the biggest contributor to the state's
wos with an $840,000 median home price
which of course is also the highest in
the nation estimates suggest that 44% of
households in the state do not earn
enough to pay for the absolute Bare
Bones of Necessities after all much of
the work available is low wage service
sector jobs relating to the tourism
industry so in consequence native
Hawaiian the descendants of those who've
inhabited the islands for a millennia
are packing up and leaving the state on
mass in fact for the first time the 2020
census indicated that the majority of
Hawaiians now live not in Hawaii but on
the mainland but at least finally there
appears to be some recognition that the
way Hawaii feeds itself is broken over
recent years the government in Honolulu
has started to put a concerted effort
into returning things to the way they
were or at least moving in that
direction and the timing is Right Dole's
aahu Plantation stopped production in
the 9s and since has transformed into a
tourist destination Del Monte another
agriculture giant finished its
operations in the state in 2008 while
Hawaii's last Sugar Mill that of Maui
closed in 2016 so that means there are
huge swaths of former Plantation land
now empty and available in the states
trying to put it to use Maui's former
sugar Plantation for example was
purchased in 2018 by a company called
Maui Pono which has converted the fields
into production of lemons oranges
avocados bananas onions and more a
diversified array of crops grown not for
exports but rather to be inserted
directly into the Hawaiian supply chain
hitting store shelves in Walmart Costco
Safeway and other retailers that
otherwise would import from the mainland
and this fits into a concerted cross
government effort to convert Plantation
land Statewide but it's really too early
to tell whether this is yielding results
there's just not enough data yet and
local food production also isn't in of
itself a direct solution to the issues
presented by the state's current
situation the cost of Labor is still
extremely high so in many cases the cost
of locally grown Goods might be at par
with outside products the decrease in
transportation costs is counterbalanced
with the increase in production costs
but it's a start incremental progress
towards reversing A Century of Reliance
on the mainland it's really quite rare
for a country to hold land so far from
its core there are some instances but
most country's land is contiguous it's
rarer still for that land to be
organized not as a territory existing in
some separated class and enjoying some
higher level of autonomy but rather as a
fully integrated component of the
country itself in this case a state but
even among those rayon the Canary
Islands and perhaps a few others it is
rarer perhaps unprecedented for land so
far from the country's core to be so
deeply integrated politically
economically and socially with the rest
of it it is therefore reasonable to
conclude that this isn't natural it's a
uniquely American thing to attempt to
Interlink itself with a series of
islands so far away in some ways this
has worked just look at the strip malls
and fast food chains and big box retail
but in actuality Hawaii was not truly
interl with the US it was conquered
there was an equilibrium Hawaii was a
self-sustaining Society until America
came in and broke that tenuous balance
decades upon Decades of economic forces
have compounded the effects and today
the states in an unsustainable state
food housing everything just cost too
much compared to the wages earned in the
state there's not yet some Grand
solution even in increased local food
production will take ages to induce
meaningful change but at the very least
the state now recognizes the problem the
Hawaiian Kingdom may never return but
Hawaiian self-reliance
can as far as American states go Hawaii
is just about one of the most difficult
to research and write a fair and
accurate script about with a long proud
history as an Empire itself and an even
longer history as an independent culture
and society that still persists to this
very day navigating and understanding
current trends and news events like the
line of wildfires without recognizing
and thus replicating biases on how the
rest of the US understands and often
oversimplifies haai current events
proved timeconsuming it only makes sense
though that news outlets that rely on
clicks to turn advertising revenues
present tragedies like the Lina fire in
incendiary and highly partisan ways but
there is a way to cut through the slant
and the noise that's ground news the
sponsor for this video by looking into
the Lina fire with the help of ground
news it becomes clear that the Centrist
and left leading Outlets have spent more
time covering the tragedy the state's
response to the tragedy and the
underlying routes of the tragedy while
the right has been practically silent on
the topic with such an imbalance and
coverage between left and right ground
news identifies the topic as a blind
spot which is one of my favorite
features on the platform with blind spot
users can see what stories aren't
getting any representation in left or
right leaning news diets and can go
ahead and view subjects that are in
their own blind spots something that
allows me to identify and take in news
that otherwise wouldn't be surfaced in
my own media diet with blind spot bot
along with features such as bias ratings
factuality ratings and information on
media ownership structures ground news
has helped me identify the limitations
and leanings in my own media diet while
also helping me find sources for videos
like this that I can really trust if
you'd like to more comfortably cut
through the misinformation and political
leanings of news stories and sources go
to ground. news/ Windover or follow the
link in this video's description to try
ground news today and save 40% on your
subscription you'll become more Savvy in
your media consumption and you'll
support an independent news platform
focused on fact uality and transparency
while you're at it